et pour en parler on retrouve en direct
jean pierre favennec professeur à l'ifp
school et spécialiste en énergie ce jean
pierre favennec bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors on
craignait le retour de l'affrontement
entre moscou et ryad sur la production
pétrolière
comment expliquer finalement que les
deux parties soient tombés d'accord hier
m'écouter france a été près vers
expliqué dans les minutes qui viennent
de le précéder
on est sur un marché pétrolier qui reste
fragile on rappelle que l'année dernière
la baisse de la production de pétrole a
été de l'ordre de près de 10%
donc il ya eu des mesures très strictes
crise donc pas ce qu'on appelle lopez
plus est à dire l'organisation et
exportateurs de pétrole dont le leader
incontesté et l'arabie séoudite u qui
produit est dans la merde pétrole est
l'un des plus gros producteurs de
pétrole au monde si pour le plus gros
potentiellement et puis lié disons à
l'opep peut plus donc c'était l'année
dernière ont décidé de réduire leur
production il ya eu des difficultés mais
globalement c'est quand même bien
entendu pour réduire la production qui
comme toute assez intéressant c'est
qu'actuellement
comme vous l'avait déjà dit le prix du
pétrole est revenu à un niveau qui est
celui d'avant la crise alors qu'on a un
marché qui reste quand même relativement
faible le certains pays comme ça a été
mentionné regrette effectivement été ici
dès hier c'était de maintenir les
productions un niveau relativement bas
c'est à dire de réduire la production
par rapport à ce qu'elle croit être
certains pays membres de l'opep ont
regretté un peu cette décision et moi je
répète toujours qu'il vaut mieux vendre
un peu moins de pétrole
un prix supérieur plutôt que de vendre
beaucoup de pétrole à un prix qui va
s'effondrer
donc je pense la décision d'hier est une
bonne décision c'est à dire que c'est
une décision qui tient compte les aléas
du marché s'était répété le marché reste
fragile
il y as en dehors du covili a comme sont
atteints la transition énergétique
on entend un peu partout qu'il faut
produire moins de charbon bien sûr mais
également moins de pétrole ou du moins
utilisé moins d énergie fossile
on en a encore besoin pour un certain
temps c'est clair on ne passera pas tout
de suite à tout électrique
c'est évident savoir comme pas mal
d'années mais il est clair que le coc
vide et la production énergétique
ce sont des menaces pour le marché
pétrolier donc les pays producteurs au
premier lieu desquels l'arabie saoudite
est également
la russie sont conscients de cela et
donc ont intérêt à maintenir une
production limitée mais hier à faire en
sorte que le prix ne s'effondrent pas
dernière chose je crois qu'un troisième
acteur qui n'a pas été indiqué dans la
dans la discussion était très présent ce
sont les états unis d'amérique qui
produisent beaucoup de pétrole mais pour
10 beaucoup de pétrole à travers son
appel et pétrole de schiste dont les
coûts de production sont très élevés
donc un prix élevé du pétrole permet aux
producteurs de schiste américains qui
sont des petites sociétés et non pas mal
de monde de continuer à vivre à leurs
prix très bas pourraient les mettre en
difficulté et je crois que dans le
contexte géopolitique actuel était
important de maintenir un prix
relativement élevés du pétrole de
manière à permettre à tout le monde de
vivre à peu près normalement alors on
l'a bien compris un prudence et
vigilance 1 comme l'avait d'ailleurs
signalé en préambule de cette réunion le
ministre saoudien de l'énergie je
voudrais que l'on parle du kazakhstan
mais surtout de la russie on sait que
les deux pays se sont vus accorder des
quotas de production supplémentaires
pourquoi ce privilège
je crois que là il est fondamental que
la russie est donc le cas d'accident
euros par le kazakhstan les papilles
producteurs de pétrole relativement
important s'il s'en vouloir trop ennuyer
des auditeurs avec des chiffres on a
trois très gros producteurs sont les
etats-unis la russie et l'arabie
saoudite que des productions qui sont
hors de 10 pouces 15 millions de barils
par jour selon les moments
le kazakhstan sait moins c'est 3
millions de barils par jour mais pour
les pour la russe pour l'arabie séoudite
ça a été dit les ventes de pétrole de
l'essentiel des recettes budgétaires et
elles sont nécessaires
on la russie ça reste quelque chose de
très important pour le kazakhstan
également donc un prix du pétrole
relativement élevé et une production
relativement importante
ce sont des sources de revenus tout à
fait nécessaire et donc été assez
logique que ces deux pays puissent
bénéficier ans en échange je dirais leur
solidarité avec les grands producteurs
comme l'arabie saoudite d'une petite
d'un petit coup de pouce pour améliorer
leur production
est ce qu'aujourd'hui on peut dire que
crise ou pas crise finalement l'arabie
saoudite et est toujours le maître du
pétrole mondial
écoutez choix qu'on peut dire ça on peut
dire seul arabi souhaite je répète
souvent est le seul pays qui en principe
dispose de capacités excédentaires de
production c'est à dire que elle
pourrait si elle le voulait produire
davantage de pétrole
et ça le fait délibérément à la une
volonté de contrôler entre guillemets
bien sur le marché mondial et elle fait
en sorte d'avoir des capacités
excédentaires non utilisées qui en cas
de crise dans un pays majeur
exportateurs de pétrole on peut prendre
un autre pays du golfe par exemple ou un
autre pays africain il ya surtout
soldats passent aujourd'hui à mende
s'est jamais et bien d'arabie séoudite
se dit toujours prête à augmenter
considérablement et assez rapidement sa
production
peut-être de sachants misa million et
demi de barils par jour le principe il
est là et l'arabie saoudite est
pratiquement pas actuellement la
situation est différente puisque avec
l'actrice ducobu chacun a réduit un
petit peu sa production mais jusqu'à une
époque récente l'arabie saoudite était
pratiquement le seul pays capable
d'augmenter assez rapidement et de
manière sensible
sa production de pétrole pour faire face
à un éventuel déficit donc c'est bien la
volonté d'arabie saoudite de créer de
contrôler le marché comme d'ailleurs à
le faire un petit peu depuis la fameuse
rencontre
je remonte à 1945 et à la rencontre dite
du point 6 entre le roi saoud le
fondateur d'arabie séoudite et le
président roosevelt et depuis on sait
que c'est à cet important est la
position de l'arabie saoudite quelles
que soient les des problèmes
géopolitiques l'on peut rencontrer les
l'homme la position de l'arabie saoudite
reste une position extrêmement solide
par avis et audi dispose de réserves
tout à fait importante même si
apparemment le venezuela les propos les
réserves les plus importantes à la pâte
signification et réserver les u17
augmenté par le président chavez pour
des raisons politiques que l'on peut
comprendre et de très loin le pays
dispose des réserves les plus faciles et
plus importante peut être trop vite
rapidement c'est l'arabie souris merci
beaucoup en tout cas jean pierre
favennec d'avoir répondu à nos questions
j'en rappelle que vous êtes professeur
ali espèces ou les spécialistes en
énergie